[Música]
un nuevo caso de abuso policial
conmociona a Estados Unidos la muerte de
un joven afroamericano en manos de cinco
policías también afroamericanos en la
ciudad de Memphis vuelve a poner sobre
la mesa la discusión sobre el excesivo
uso de la fuerza
después de su reunión en Caracas con
Nicolás Maduro el alto comisionado de la
ONU para los Derechos Humanos pidió al
presidente venezolano liberar a las
personas detenidas arbitrariamente y
poner fin a la tortura
el canciller Alemán Olaf shows llegó a
Argentina donde iniciará su gira
inaugural por Sudamérica el mandatario
fue recibido por el presidente Alberto
Fernández con quien discutió el acuerdo
comercial entre la Unión Europea y el
mercosur
[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos donde hay conmoción
después de que la policía de Memphis
publicara el vídeo en el que se ve a
cinco policías dándole una paliza al
joven afroamericano tyry Nichols Quien
murió tres días más tarde Aunque el caso
recuerda a la muerte de George Floyd en
2020 las protestas esta vez han sido más
tímidas lluís Muñoz con los detalles
a la izquierda Mineápolis 2020 George
Floyd y su No puedo respirar
a la derecha Memphis 2023 tairi Nichols
y un último grito mamá
casos diferentes pero una coincidencia
dos afroamericanos que murieron a manos
de la policía algo sistemático como
analizó para France 24 el activista anti
racista raudemar o Fungi dentro de la
misma policía sabemos que hay un racismo
sistemático pero a la misma vez el mismo
sistema lo involucra y los hace cometer
este este acto
en el caso de George Floyd el principal
responsable Drake showbing era un
policía blanco Eso desató la ira entre
la sociedad surgiendo el movimiento de
las vidas negras importan las protestas
antirracistas más grandes en décadas en
Estados Unidos en el caso de tariri
Nichols los policías involucrados igual
que la víctima eran afroamericanos
también su jefa y además esta comunidad
representa el 65% de la ciudad de
Memphis la pregunta que todos no hacemos
y todo se hacen o que todos los
comentarios dicen Bueno pero fueron
cinco policías negros no fueron blancos
está bien pero el punto está que el
sistema policial de manera sistemática
entrena prepara y psicológicamente
prepara a policía para autodestruir Y no
y no defender
según el sitio web mapping police
violence en 2022 se alcanzó el récord de
los últimos 10 años con 1186 personas
muertas en intervenciones policiales una
cuatro víctimas fue afroamericana en
este contexto el presidente Joe biden
Busca una reforma policial a nivel
Federal mientras 340 ciudades ya lo han
hecho un nivel local y seis estados por
ejemplo han restringido las órdenes
emitidas por jueces para que la policía
pueda entrar en un inmueble sin
notificación previa vamos a Venezuela el
alto comisionado de la ONU para los
Derechos Humanos Walker turk llegó a
Caracas para reunirse con el presidente
Nicolás Maduro otros representantes del
gobierno y la sociedad civil su visita
se da Después del más reciente informe
de esta oficina de la ONU publicado el
pasado mes de junio el documento resalta
que aunque ha habido avances aún
existían preocupaciones sobre la falta
de independencia del sistema judicial
mandatario a liberar a las personas
detenidas arbitrariamente y poner fin a
la tortura
escuché relatos de personas detenidas
arbitrariamente y torturadas y
familiares asesinados en operaciones de
seguridad y manifestaciones
una mujer se llenó de emoción al contar
cómo hace dos años su hermana había sido
detenida violada y torturada
en mis reuniones con el presidente y los
ministros pedir la liberación de todas
las personas que habían sido detenidas
arbitrariamente
el canciller Alemán olafels llegó este
sábado a Buenos Aires Argentina que será
El Punto de partida de su gira inaugural
por Sudamérica y que también lo llevará
a chile y Brasil las principales
economías de la región shows fue
recibido por el presidente Alberto
Fernández junto a quien ofreció una
rueda de prensa tras un encuentro en el
que dialogaron sobre el acuerdo
bilateral en el marco de los acuerdos
entre la Unión Europea y el mercosur
escuchemos ambos coincidimos en que la
profundización de nuestras relaciones
comerciales alberga un enorme potencial
claro
que el acuerdo Unión Europea mercosur
tiene una especial importancia para ello
y ahora Nuestro objetivo es llegar por
fin a una rápida conclusión de las
invasiones
a América Latina al mercosur
puntualmente
le serviría a Europa y también
permitiría trazar un eje que de algún
modo
potencie el multilateralismo en un mundo
que tiende otra vez a bipolarizarse
decenas de personas de la comunidad
indígena llanomami ubicada en la
amazonía de Brasil están yendo a
hospitales por enfermedades que aseguran
son causadas por la minería ilegal en
los últimos tiempos ha habido un repunte
de malaria por los pozos de agua que
deja la explotación minera y de
contaminación con mercurio una situación
que se agravó durante la gestión de la
pasada presidencia de Jair bolsonaro
Ramiro cué barbarena nos cuenta más
neumonía malaria diarrea infecciones de
piel y desnutrición infantil en
distintos grados la comunidad llanumami
de Brasil continúa sufriendo las
condiciones vulnerables de vida y la
ausencia de asistencia de salud
muchos están enfermos no hay comida
muchos de nuestros familiares han muerto
muchos ya no mamían muerto
se estima que 30.000 viven en el
territorio indígena más grande que tiene
Brasil equivalente al tamaño de Portugal
y donde 570 niños han muerto en los
últimos 3 años las enfermedades del
pueblo indígena desbordan la capacidad
del hospital de niños Santo Antonio el
único del estado de roraima al que
acuden en graves condiciones menores que
tienen entre 29 días y 12 años
las miradas apuntan a la aceleración de
la explotación minera que contaminó Ríos
mató animales arrebató fuentes de agua
potable generó charcos que originan
enfermedades y ocupó a los pocos
espacios sanitarios
nos quedamos cuatro años sin asistencia
sanitaria en las comunidades 120
comunidades luchando por la vida más de
20.000 Mineros de oro en tierra indígena
llanomami con armas intimidando las
comunidades comunidades que viven con
miedo
el último 20 de enero el Gobierno
Federal declaró una emergencia de salud
pública y desde entonces se tendieron
hospitales de campaña para auxiliar a la
comunidad la situación de los yanumami
se agravó seriamente durante el gobierno
de Jair bolsonaro durante su mandato las
muertes dentro del grupo indígena de la
selva amazónica aumentaron un
28%. y terminamos con una buena noticia
porque México los esfuerzos para salvar
a los marsopas en peligro de extinción
están viendo resultados positivos
después de muchos años de lucha luego de
que en 2018 los biólogos estimaran que
quedaban menos de 20 ejemplares el
trabajo conjunto del gobierno y de una
organización medioambiental ha cambiado
la metodología veamos más detalles en el
siguiente informe de Marta Moya
avances para proteger a las marsopas en
México en el Golfo de California viven
estas vaquitas marinas en peligro de
extinción cuya protección Lleva más de
un año en manos del trabajo conjunto
entre el gobierno y la organización sin
fines de lucro c# la operación milagro
como se ha llamado trata de compartir
información sobre el área donde viven
estos animales para evitar males mayores
por el momento se han logrado reducir el
70% de las horas de pesca de los barcos
en las zonas donde están las marsopas
cuando la población tiene pocos
individuos los que quedan se contraen
espacialmente en el lugar en el que se
sienten por decirlo coloquialmente más a
gusto el lugar donde encuentran su
alimento y su hábitat preferido por eso
es que el gobierno estableció esta zona
con una prohibición total de todo tipo
de redes la lucha por la protección de
estos animales no es nueva los esfuerzos
por mantener viva la especie se
redoblaron a partir de 2018 cuando los
biólogos estimaron que solo quedaban
entre 6 y 20 dólares la mayor parte de
ellas mueren en las redes de pescadores
por lo que ahora la prioridad es cambiar
esa metodología hemos probado diferentes
técnicas y formas de resolver los
problemas a lo largo de los años y
durante muchos años tiramos de redes
Esta es una estrategia diferente
asegurémonos de que las redes no se
sumerjan en el agua y lo que es más
importante que si se sumergen en el agua
solo estarán allí unos minutos la lucha
para salvar a las marsopas continúa pese
a las acusaciones externas contra el
estado mexicano de aplicar una
regulación ineficaz durante años hasta
que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]